you wanna take on mitosis let me get
your diagnosis just as your husband and
I am in all your raps are necrosis yeah
I'm so perfectly perfect in all my
careful divisions creating identical
versions while your own limbs of
different don't talk to me being around
the block too many times in your typical
splitting is possibly spitting out for
me jealous cuz I'm sexy and I got two
sets of phases I like to mix DNA up when
I'm entering my prophase stages you're
like your parents kid is just like a
clone you see this chromosomal genetic
combinations my own I'm independent my
chromosomes don't need any pairs at the
end there's only 23 so your mom and dad
can share and make life yeah I'm the one
that gets you your offspring though my
genetic variant I create arrogant DNA
shoot you from New York to Beijing sure
if we're for you I wouldn't have kids
but if I wasn't here then you wouldn't
exist and those babies you keep Briana
oh real cute I'm the one that makes them
glow you can stop playing in your video
your legs heal face the only thing worth
admiring is your cleavage I don't want
to get half of my chromosomes up I felt
offended leeet's is my achievement I'm
like telophase - I like to kick back in
done wine but I'm secretly anaphase
pulling you apart from inside I repair
the whole body to make you grow big and
strong if I wanted sex cells I would
just ask your mom hey here's a question
maybe you have the answer did you know
you're the main cause for a whole bunch
of cancers yeah your errors caused a lot
of conditions coach did that burn better
call the physician sign can't feel your
burns as I can recur skin I'll prepare
to shoot bill membranes to never let you
in whatever
I've noticed one and of course miosha's
- a way more complex classes making me
way better than you - of successive
divisions for perfect daughter cells
each one ends up halfway is that your
test she's thanking me as well and I was
discovered first 1876 to be exact so I'm
older and wiser than you and that is a
fact
my overabundance of detail makes me a
bit more complex so my discovery
required a lot more contact
I come from Walter Fleming's genius mind
observations
look at this cuties be here if you give
anyone stimulation well one of my
forefathers had the hippest glasses and
peach fuzz Gert wig was a hipster before
everybody was she to me that makes the
getting to all of humanity camera crews
got a strive for diversity in progress
so we don't end up like you adieu hey
hey both our chromosomes line up at the
equator and we're mostly
interface I'll try not to be hater when
it comes to agreeing one thing we have
at least is that both our epic journeys
and in cytokinesis we should hang out
sometime yeah bro hey hey we really hope
that you like this song we're gonna put
a link in the descriptions you can get
it on iTunes and Bandcamp and let's do
it over and over instead of the
differences between mitosis and meiosis
we also want to send a huge shadow to
our friend Andrew who helped make the
beat to this song if you like songs like
this and parity videos check out his
channel got a role I could be there's a
lot of awesome stuff over there he's a
good friend and has a great channel so
make sure you subscribe a staff time I
mean wow and we'll see you next week for
more weekly science videos
[Music]